okay guys in this problem we have two
identical 12in concrete sewers that are
installed at a 2% slope and flow into a
junction manhole here their flows join
and are carried Downstream by a single
sewer also of the same size as the
others what slope does the downstream
sewer need to have in order to convey
the full flows from both Upstream sewers
does the Velocity in this sewer exceed
the minimum velocity of 2.5 ft per
second needed to prevent vent
sedimentation and fall below 15 ft per
second to prevent
scour so the first thing we need to
recognize to solve this problem is that
we're using Manning's equation our
reference manual will give us the
equation and we can see in it that Q for
flow equals
1.49 over Manning's
n
area hydraulic
radius raised to the 2/3 slope raised to
the/
12 so that is Mannings if we compare the
flow
in both of the twin 12in concrete sewers
at slope of 2% with another form of
Mannings for the other sewer whose slope
we don't know yet we can back calculate
to solve for the slope so the way we can
do this
is step one here will be
1.49 over
n
a r to the 2/3 s the
12 times two for both of the sewers
flow will
equal the sewer on the other side of the
junction
manhole and if we'd like we can simplify
this down so we know that the sewers are
all 12 in as it specifies in the problem
1.49 Over N is going to be the same
thing as
well and even our area over our wedded
perimeter should be the same if we're
assuming full flow here so really this
whole problem can simplify down pretty
quickly to
Simply we can write this out a little
more if it to explain
it remember that hydraulic radius is
area over wetted
perimeter in the interest of time on the
test you probably don't need to write
all this
out
but we're here to learn so
area over wed perimeter to the
23 slope 2 to the 12 and that was slope
one so that's the only thing that's
different so what we're going to get
down to here is slope
one *
equals slope
2 square
root and that's just by simplifying down
this original step here so if we were to
plug in the slope value of 2% expressed
as a
decimal we can solve this out
now and just like that
we can
determine that the slope of the
downstream
pipe is 8% so we know the answer is
going to be one of these two however we
can continue to check that now simply by
plugging in the
equations back into Mannings with our
new known slope and figuring out what
our velocity is so instead of using the
First full term here for Mannings we can
remove the area and simply solve for
velocity here instead so we can say V
equal
1.49 Over
N area over wed perimeter to the
23 slope to the
12 and filling this out some
more the Manning's n is going to be
0.013 for
concrete uh I'm not actually sure if
that's in the manual or not usually
it'll be given if you need it though and
then the area of a circle I'll write up
here real fast that's going to be pi d^2
over
4 so in this case that's going to be
3.14
* 1T sared over 4 that gives us
0.785 Square
ft and the perimeter the wed perimeter
in this case is just going to be Pi D so
that's going to be
3.14 *
1T gives us
3.14
ft you might even have that one
memorized if you've done a lot of
problems already you using circular
pipes so I did that up here just so we
can simplify what we're writing out down
here this is
0785 Ft squared
over
3.14 ft and all of that is to the
2/3 and our slope that we just solved
for is 0.08 to the
12 and if we solve this out in chunks
you don't have to but again if you're
working on a
calculator that isn't easy to move
around in sometimes it takes a little
more time
but I do these in chunks just to check
my work on the
way and if we solve out for all of that
we will get
12.86 ft per second so
yes that also falls
between 15 and 2.5 it's up there but
it's not quite above it so I would say
in this problem it's a slope of
8% and a velocity that falls within the
range so yes and that's all it takes to
solve this problem